so there's a story check it out that i i
was gonna
say but i wanted i wanted to wait for
for mike um
so about a year ago
i i did i did shrooms okay
and it was
[Laughter]
so so check this one out so
um and it was with a shaman you know
and she was hot they normally are they
normally i haven't know
i haven't thought that it was charming
chicken yeah it was the real deal right
it was the real deal it was at home i
felt safe you know
and so she gives me these it's like a
micro dosing right they call it right so
i take them and she starts talking to me
about my
my past like she starts telling me like
you know what what affects you as a kid
or this and that
and that when we're talking you know so
then we go into my
a room you know where she has candles
and everything and so we we sit down
and i close my eyes mike
i i turned into like i turned into like
like like a substance i i got out of my
body i turned into a substance and i
started floating
like in the galaxy it does it to you you
know
i was in and then all of a sudden all of
a sudden
i dive into the ocean okay i dive into
the ocean
and i'm just like i'm water i'm i'm i
don't know what i am
i dive and it's beautiful it's like
[ __ ] finding nemo it's beautiful
colorful everything and i keep going
down keep going down
and all of a sudden i stop and i'm
looking but it's like i'm water i'm part
of the water you know
and then behind like the seaweed there's
a there's a thing a presence
okay and all i feel
is that that's my mother you know i feel
that's my mother
and then the the thing starts bowing
down to me
and right there and then i felt that she
forgave me
you know and how how long ago was this
oscar that was a year ago
and then i shoot right back up and then
and and now i'm feeling like man she
forgave me she forgave me
and then the shaman like she speaks a
few words and says now let's go to
little oscar
and all of a sudden i see i see myself
as the seven-year-old
right in front of me you know and then
she tells me feel them closer
and he's getting closer and you feel
them closer he's getting closer and all
of a sudden i have i open my eyes
because i got scared
i got scared i i haven't been able to
face
that little oscar listen oscar you're
talking to me
and henry right now but right now
there's [ __ ] out here to think
you're crazy as a [ __ ]
you know i hear you man we've been on
that ride so we know
yeah you know this is the real deal but
now there's people looking after these
from craters it's deep it's deep no
oscar you talk about fruit do you feel
like you need forgiveness for your mom
you think your mom would be dis you know
what i'm saying like elaborate
touch up on that oscar i think there's a
lot of um
i think there's a lot in us a lot in me
that that i have to release and work on
and let go and
because there's a lot of pain you know
there's a lot of [ __ ] pain